bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public on est
ensemble du lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h
sur Public Sénat vous le savez pour
donner du sens à l'actualité grâce à nos
invités experts 90 minutes et deux
grands thèmes d'actualité ce soir Lille
italienne de Lampedusa confronté à une
nouvelle arrivée de réfugiés une île
symbole d'une Europe des 27 qui peinent
à trouver une réponse commune aux crises
migratoires c'est aussi un piège pour la
première ministre italienne Georgia
Meloni qui avait promis un blocus naval
à ses électeurs des atermoiements
européens aux récupération politique de
tout bord on analyse les conséquences de
ce qui est aussi un drame humain dans
une minute et puis c'est un fléau qui
frappe notre économie depuis plus de
deux ans et qui aggrave la pauvreté
l'inflation reste à des niveaux élevés
Fabien Roussel il voit un séisme social
pour la France
[Applaudissements]
des factures d'électricité de l'essence
du caddie ils sont écrasés par ces prix
qui augmentent
alimentation carburant salaire que peut
faire le gouvernement sa dernière
décision revenir sur l'interdiction de
la vente à perdre c'était interdit
depuis 1963 est-ce que ça peut vraiment
faire baisser le prix de l'essence
réponse dans 45 minutes mais d'abord
cette île au milieu de la Méditerranée
porte d'entrée vers le soi-disant
Eldorado européen c'est Lampedusa au
bord de l'asphyxie Flora sauvage
ainsi recroqueviller a même le sol ils
sont 8500 migrants en provenance
d'Afrique du Nord à être arrivé en
quelques jours à Lampedusa soit plus que
l'ensemble de la population de l'île
italienne une situation qui a mis les
capacités d'accueil de l'île sous
tension des péchés en urgence à Rome à
la demande d'Emmanuel Macron ce lundi
soir Gérald Darmanin doit livrer un
message de fermeté à son homologue
italien à nos amis italiens qui je crois
sont parfaitement d'accord avec nous
nous devons protéger les frontières
extérieures de l'Union européenne les
aider à cela et surtout tout de suite
regarder les demandes d'asile et quand
les
tout de suite les renvoyer dans leur
pays selon la France la réponse à la
crise migratoire ne peut être que
européenne en visite à lampedus à
dimanche la présidente de la Commission
européenne
Ursula vanderleyen a présenté un plan
d'urgence parmi les mesures annoncées le
renforcement des effectifs des gardes
frontières de l'UE et le versement d'une
aide à la Tunisie pour limiter les
départs l'immigration irrégulière est un
défi européen qui nécessite une réponse
européenne donc nous sommes là dedans
ensemble un message d'apaisement en
direction de Giorgia Meloni la chef du
gouvernement italien avait reproché à
ses partenaires européens leur manque de
solidarité envers l'Italie depuis le
début de l'année son pays a accueilli
sur son territoire 130 000 personnes
près du double comparé à 2022 sur la
même période je ne considère pas tant ce
geste comme un geste de solidarité de
l'Europe en vers l'Italie mais plutôt
comme un geste de responsabilité de
l'Europe envers elle-même parce qu'il ne
s'agit pas seulement des frontières de
l'Italie mais aussi des frontières de
l'Europe face à la flux de migrants à
ses frontières la première ministre
italienne a promis un nouveau tour de
Vistre en allongeant notamment la durée
maximale de rétention des immigrés
illégaux 235 jours à 18 mois
le thème de l'immigration l'Europe au
pied du mur on en débat tout de suite
avec Rachel binaz bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes journaliste au service sociétés à
Marianne en charge notamment de ces
questions d'immigration Patrick Martin
Genier bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous
êtes professeur à Sciences Po
spécialiste des questions européennes et
vous publiez ce livre l'Europe à tel un
avenir aux éditions Studyrama Richard
Verly bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous êtes
correspondants en France Europe pour le
média suisse Blick j'accueille également
Mathieu croissant Mathieu bonsoiriste
politique bienvenue à vous on va
redémarrer à partir de ce chiffre que
vous avez entendu dans le dans le sujet
de Flora sauvage c'est l'agence des
Nations Unies pour les migrations qui
nous donne ce chiffre d'environ 8500
migrants qui ont débarqué c'était entre
lundi et mercredi la semaine dernière à
Lampedusa au bord de 199 bateaux pour
information il y a 6300 habitants de
selon le dernier recensement qui date de
2015 à Lampedusa Rachel binasse
peut-être qu'est-ce qu'on sait de ces
migrants est-ce qu'on connaît forcément
leur pays d'origine tiens est-ce que
c'est aussi simple de répondre à cette
question alors tout d'abord je me
permets de rectifier le chiffre entre
c'est le chiffre du ministère de
l'Intérieur italien entre le 10 et le 16
on est à plus de 12000 migrants
italien moi on a choisi celui de la
journée bien sûr et puis ce sont des
chiffres qui sont qui sont croissants
même si là les passeurs rencontre un
petit problème ni ils attendaient des
bateaux qui ne viennent pas donc les
passages ont tendance à diminuer ce que
l'on sait en effet c'est que donc c'est
une île une petite île à 150 km des
côtes tunisiennes qui amènent
régulièrement cette cette migration
concernant les nationalités les profils
on les connaît un petit peu grosso modo
trois rives en tête la Guinée la Côte
d'Ivoire et la Tunisie c'est les
principales nationalités sachant
qu'environ 30 à 34% des migrants qui
sont sur place à Lampedusa sont ce qu'on
appelle non documentés c'est-à-dire ne
veulent pas déclarer leur nationalité
donc il y a tout un travail
d'identification qui est à faire ce qui
également pour ensuite des questions
pour les qualifier entrer en quelque
sorte sont-ils demandeurs d'asile ou pas
ça dépend évidemment beaucoup de du pays
d'origine on reviendra un petit peu plus
tard Patrick Martin Genier c'est pas la
première crise du genre à Lampedusa
est-ce qu'elle vous semble plus grave
que les précédentes vous voyez je crois
que elle est très grave parce que il y a
un afflux considérable de migrants dont
beaucoup ne sont pas nécessairement des
réfugiés et en fait on voit bien les
limites de l'action d'un état il faut
dire que Georgia Meloni avait accès
toute sa campagne électorale sur le
thème de l'immigration le contrôle de
l'immigration c'est un échec pour elle
mais pour autant l'Europe a une part de
responsabilité pourquoi nous avons
laissé l'Italie depuis des années ce
n'est pas nouveau cette crise migratoire
l'Italie l'Espagne la Grèce sont parmi
des premiers pays à accueillir ces
demandeurs d'asile et je crois que si
vous pouvez dire qu'elle est plus grave
parce qu'il y a peut-être plus de
migrants qui qui sont arrivés en peu de
temps parce que ça s'accumule alors que
l'Europe avait annoncé un certain nombre
de mesures si vous voulez sur petite île
symboliquement des migrants qui sont
plus importants que la population de
cette petite île qui est située
simplement à 550 km des frontières de la
frontière Tunisie des côtes tunisiennes
alors que il y a effectivement en Grèce
en Espagne depuis des années
effectivement des migrants également qui
débarquaient je dirais que là
aujourd'hui il y a une responsabilité
européenne et le fait que Ursula fonda
lion s'est rendu sur place c'est très
important l'Europe qui va réagir on en
parlera peut-être mais a eu en fait une
réaction un peu tardive car ça fait des
années qu'on parle d'un renforcement des
effectifs de Frontex qu'on parle d'une
solidarité européenne qui a eu du mal à
se mettre en place et on détaillera les
mesures d'urgence de plus long terme
annoncé par celui-là sanderline Richard
Berly est-ce que vous parlez d'un état
d'urgence migratoire ce soir oui
absolument et je crois que pour ajouter
à ce qui vient d'être dit c'est le crise
de lampirisa elle est plus grave parce
que si vous regardez les autres points
chauds migratoires de l'Union européenne
c'est-à-dire vous avez l'est avec avec
la question vous souvenez de la
Biélorussie qui déversait des gens vers
la Pologne vous avez bien sûr les flots
de migrants d'Ukraine vous avez la
Turquie avec la Grèce sur les autres
fronts ça c'est plutôt amélioré et
d'ailleurs pas toujours il faut bien le
dire parce que des solutions je dirais
humanitaires ont été trouvés aussi parce
que des murs ont été érigés des murs ont
été rigés par la Hongrie par la Pologne
par la Grèce mais grosso modo la
situation s'est stabilisée dans ces
zones l'endroit où ça ne se stabilise
pas c'est l'Italie et ça se stabilise
pas pour deux raisons d'abord parce que
les moyens promis par l'Europe ne se
sont pas concrétisés regardez le fameux
hotspot le centre d'accueil et le tri
des demandeurs
mais il est prévu pour 400 places et on
vient de parler de plusieurs milliers de
personnes c'est vous dire la
disproportion entre ce qui a été fait et
les besoins et globalement comme vous le
savez la rivalité politique voir le duel
entre les autorités italiennes et le
reste de l'Europe à compliquer la donne
donc c'est aujourd'hui le talon
d'Achille c'est le cas de le dire pour
la botte italienne c'est le talon
d'Achille migrateur de l'Europe
juste une chose parce qu'il faut quand
même préciser il y a eu 127 000 arrivées
depuis janvier en Italie ce qui est un
chiffre qui est beaucoup plus élevé que
les années précédentes sans atteindre
non plus les records 2016 127
000 127000 personnes c'est
0,03 % de la population européenne je
pense qu'il faut aussi le dire parce que
on parle bien sûr de mouvement
obligatoire colossal voilà c'est quand
même d'ailleurs je vous pose la même
question à séminin est-ce que vous
parlez vous aussi d'un état d'urgence
migratoire il y a un état d'urgence en
effet c'est un défi en réalité cette
question c'est pas une affaire italienne
c'est une affaire aussi française
éminemment puisque on le sait un certain
nombre des nationalités qui sont
présentes qui font partie des
nationalités les plus présentes à
l'empiler actuellement ce sont des
francophones pour certains qui ont envie
de rejoindre une diaspora une communauté
qui peut se trouver notamment en France
et puis bien sûr c'est c'est un sujet
européen la question des des frontières
à partir du moment on a parlé des murs à
partir du moment où on élève un mur
c'est un aveu d'échec c'est une front
qu'on ne sait pas qu'on ne s'est pas
maîtriser qui ne s'est pas régulé donc
bien sûr qu'à un enjeu de taille qui se
pose aujourd'hui à la France à l'Europe
et qui sera certainement on pourra en
reparler l'enjeu de la campagne de la
campagne évidemment qui se dérouleront
au mois au mois de juin prochain face à
ces migrants le ministre de l'Intérieur
français qui est ce soit sur place à
l'ampedousa lui alors il fait le
distinguo entre vous avez commencé à le
faire entre demandeurs les demandeurs
d'asile et les autres on écoute Gérald
Darmanin
il ne peut pas avoir comme message donné
aux personnes qui viennent sur notre sol
qui sont quoi qu'il arrive dans nos pays
accueillis ils sont accueillis que s'ils
respectent les règles de l'asile s'ils
sont persécutés mais si c'est une
immigration qui est juste irrégulière
non la France ne peut pas les accueillir
comme d'autres pays Richard Berly c'est
on peut parler économique
ce dont là Gérald Darmanin dit que l'or
ne veut pas sauf qu'elle en a besoin de
l'Europe de ses émigrés économiques on
est en pénurie de main d'oeuvre
alors l'Europe n'a pas besoin de cas
certains pays d'Europe certains pays
d'Europe ont besoin de main d'oeuvre
mais il faut quand même s'entendre sur
les termes là vous voyez largement
arriver des jeunes des jeunes hommes qui
pour beaucoup pour une grande majorité
n'ont pas de formation et je ne crois
pas qu'on puisse dire comme ça que
l'Europe on a besoin il y a des besoins
dans certains métiers présumés sous
tension y compris les métiers de service
mais ce serait aller rapidement que de
faire le lien entre les deux je crois
que la difficulté alors là je vais
revenir sur un débat franco-français qui
qui ont dit clairement fait passer le
message que c'était pas seulement des
bacs plus 5 dont ils avaient besoin oui
mais oui mais si si vous voulez mettre
les deux en rapport ça supposerait que
ces jeunes qui arrivent aujourd'hui sont
capables immédiatement de s'intéresser
sur le marché du travail français pour
prendre le cas de la France je ne crois
pas je crois que la difficulté c'est
qu'en fait la frontière que kebab Gérald
Darmanin entre demandeurs d'asile et
réfugiés elles n'existe plus vous avez
des hommes et des femmes qui sont sur le
sol européen qui ont fui leur pays et
qui et avec lesquels on n'est pas
capable d'imaginer une solution ni le
retour ni l'accueil c'est ça le problème
Patrick Martin est-ce qu'on sait faire
la différence oui mais vite la vraie
question elle est là la différence vite
en train de demander un asile ou un
immigré c'est ça la difficulté en France
vous avez des organismes tel que leur
fille de l'office français des
protection des réfugiés et des
apatriques il y a les quais partout dans
l'Union européenne puis on appelle vous
avez une course qui s'appelle la Cour
nationale du droit d'asile et donc oui
on est capable de le faire le la
difficulté aujourd'hui c'est la lenteur
il y a trois causes essentiellement de
réfugiés les gens qui fuient la guerre
les conflits les dictatures comme au
Venezuela il y a beaucoup de réfugiés
Venezuela en France il y a aussi les
gens qui craignent pour leur orientation
sexuelle en Afrique notamment et enfin
pour leurs problèmes ethnique il y a des
ethnies qui sont persécutés donc on est
capable de faire effectivement la
différence la difficulté vous l'avez dit
c'est de le faire rapidement et ce qui
se passe en effet sur les spots c'est ça
la difficulté c'est qu'on n'est pas
capable de traiter ces demandes d'asile
rapidement et tout cela qu'il faut faire
en effet c'est à dire que en premier
ressort et en appel il faudrait que ça
ne prenne pas plus d'un mois deux mois
bon ça peut prendre plusieurs mois c'est
ça aujourd'hui la difficulté pendant ce
temps-là ces personnes sont dans les
pays occidentaux et c'est pour ça que
certains pays tels que l'Italie
l'Allemagne ne souhaite plus recevoir
des demandeurs d'asile parce que ça
prend trop de temps et vous l'avez dit
la difficulté c'est le renvoie une fois
normalement que l'asile est refusé et
bien il y a une autre opération c'est ce
dont parler le médiateur c'est le renvoi
effectif et c'est là où ça coince en
effet on va parler de la réponse
européenne on va y consacrer un chapitre
entier mais une anecdote personnelle
pardon mais au début des années 90 je
faisais pour TF1 reportage sur l'OFPRA
et le thème du reportage c'était déjà
c'est beaucoup trop long le gouvernement
donne des moyens pour passer de de 10 à
8 mois ou 6 mois le pour pourquoi on y
arrive pas d'après vous parce que ça
fait là je vous donne un exemple ça fait
30 ans qu'on dit exactement la même
chose tu ne serais pas aussi sévère
parce que quand on regarde justement les
délais que ce soit les délais de
décision de l'OFPRA ou de la CNDA par
exemple la Cour nationale du droit
d'asile qui traite donc en appel comme
ça a été très bien expliqué les délais
ont plutôt tendance à se réduire il y a
un gros effort qui a été fait par la foi
on est alors ça dépend mais on va dire
qu'il faut peut-être 8 6 8 10 mois selon
les dossiers selon les on sait comment
c'était déjà les chiffres qu'on me
donnait à l'époque mais on s'est quand
même bien amélioré eu égard aussi au
nombre au nombre de dossiers qui est à
traiter il faut imaginer ce que c'est
NBA
ensuite la question elle a été elle a
été évoquée c'est celle du non seulement
lors du renvoi c'est-à-dire dans quelle
mesure on se donne les moyens d'éloigner
les personnes lorsqu'elles devraient
faire la demande d'asile et ça c'est
c'est un véritable problème mais ensuite
on pourra l'évoquer plus tard la
question des dublinets par exemple
d'Italie les dubinets alors il faut
expliquer ce que c'est bien sûr j'ai
préparé l'émission je peux comprendre
votre phrase mais mais avant d'avoir
préparé l'émission JE pas compris donc
dites-nous ce à quoi ça référence qui
relèvent de ce qu'on appelle le
règlement de Dublin 3 il y a une règle
en Europe qui est plus ou moins bien
respectée plutôt moins que plus qui veut
que un migrant dépose sa demande d'asile
dans son dans le premier pays qu'il
traverse donc là en l'occurrence
l'Italie
ne le fait pas pour environ on va dire
un tiers des migrants qui se présentent
repartir et le pays le deuxième pays
dans lequel ces migrants arrivent s'ils
sont déboutés on doit les renvoyer en
Italie
mais l'Italie refuse de les reprendre et
lorsque même ils ont déposé une demande
d'asile je finirai là-dessus ils ont
déposé une demande d'asile en Italie ils
peuvent en former ce qui a un problème
en former une par exemple en France et
bien on ne les renvoie pas non plus en
Italie c'est-à-dire que le premier pays
d'accueil qui est censé être responsable
de son migrants en l'état ne l'est pas
alors justement cette réponse européenne
je vous propose d'abord une réaction
celle
d'Emmanuel Macron ne pas laisser
l'Italie seul face à cette afflux de
migrants de voir collectif voilà ce que
le chef de l'État rappelait vendredi
dernier notre devoir à tous européen
c'est de ne pas laisser l'Italie seul
face à ce qu'elle vit aujourd'hui je
vais le dire très sincèrement à tous nos
amis italiens je considère que c'est la
responsabilité de l'Union européenne
l'Union européenne toute entière d'être
aux côtés de l'Italie mais ceci montre
si je puis me permettre cette remarque
que les approches strictement
nationalistes on leur limite et que
quand on parle de ce sujet
on est tous très heureux d'avoir la
solidarité européenne c'est bien l'Union
européenne voilà le plan de l'Union
européenne c'est le thème de la
chronique de Quentin Calmet bonsoir
Quentin bonsoir bienvenue à vous sur ce
plateau Ursula vanderline qui a donc
présenté un plan d'urgence que
contient-il précisément c'est vrai que
dans le flot de toutes ces images
impressionnantes qui viennent de lampe
P12 ans on a vu une que on a voulu
retenir c'est celle de toutes ces
dizaines d'embarcations récupérées ces
derniers jours allant p12a et qui
s'annonçait maintenant autour de Lille
et bien justement un des 10 points du
plan présenté hier vise justement à
lutter contre la logistique des passeurs
et par exemple à rendre inutilisable les
bateaux récupérés plus globalement le
plan fixe des priorités et surtout celui
et bien de développer le travail des
agences de l'Union européenne à
Lampedusa comme par exemple l'a EUA qui
est l'agence de l'Union européenne pour
l'asile et qui va donc et bien en
développant son action pouvoir traiter
plus rapidement les dossiers c'est un
débat essentiel en vous en parliez
justement dans le système Schengen autre
agence au coeur du plan c'est Frontex le
Corps européen des gardes frontières et
des gardes côte la Commission veut ainsi
renforcer la surveillance des frontières
en mer avec des moyens supplémentaires
et le plan opérationnel comme dit la
Commission vise également un faciliter
le transfert des personnes vers d'autres
États membres sur la base d'un mécanisme
de solidarité volontaire en appliquant
et appliquer un sien récent un corps
avec la Tunisie pour et bien mieux
renvoyer les migrants vers ses côtés
alors ça quand un c'est le plan
d'urgence mais ça fait trois ans que la
Commission européenne tente de faire
voter par les États membres ou une
réforme de l'asile et de l'immigration
voilà il y a les mesures opérationnelles
qu'on vient d'évoquer il y a aussi les
mesures législatives de l'Union pour
changer améliorer la gestion du dossier
migrotin en Europe et cela fait trois
ans on peut le dire que l'Union
européenne a développé a dévoilé un
nouveau pack de migration et d'asile
c'était en septembre 2020 d'où le masque
l'idée de ce plan était de répondre à la
crise migratoire des années 2015-2016
avec l'arrivée à l'époque de centaines
de milliers de réfugiés syriens en Grèce
et selon Ursula la finale il s'agissait
avec ce paquet de mesures d'un nouveau
départ c'est donc ça fait 3 ans que ça
négocie c'est vers à Bruxelles et à
Strasbourg vous voyez les grandes lignes
de cette réforme qui est donc toujours
en cours de négociation déjà il y a le
fait de durcir les renvois des migrants
irréguliers et de mettre en place des
contrôles accrus aux frontières
extérieur également des procédures
accélérées surtout pour des
ressentissants venus de pays où il vient
la demande d'asile et largement refusé
enfin il met en place un mécanisme de
solidarité envers les États membres
alors évidemment pourquoi ça pourquoi ça
prend autant de temps parce que chaque
pays a ses intérêts son agenda en
quelque sorte exactement on avait vu les
pays de vise grade la Pologne la Hongrie
la Slovaquie encore la public tchèque et
bien s'opposer à ce paquet de mesures
mais et bien on a beaucoup avancé en
juin dernier lors des dernières une
réunion du Conseil européen des
ministres de l'Intérieur et donc
maintenant on voit que les deux
prochains conseils européens sont et
bien sur cette sur ce pacte sur les
négociations autour de ce pacte et on
dit que les 27 pourraient conclure et
bien dans les prochains mois et bien on
suivra ça merci beaucoup Quentin Richard
VI je me tourne vers vous on va rentrer
un peu dans le détail vous avez parlé
des hotspots tout à l'heure les centres
de rétention on touche du doigt une
forme quoi d'impuissance européenne sur
ce dossier migratoire on touche du doigt
deux choses d'abord il y a une ambiguïté
qu'il va falloir un jour lever et qu'on
retrouve dans les termes employés on
parle de hotspot alors que ce sont des
camps de rétention et des camps de
rétention qu'il va falloir équiper
d'abord il va falloir en construire des
grands camps il faut quand même
l'admettre même si c'est difficile à
entendre c'est une obligation il va
falloir construire dans ces camps des
unités de tri justement pour trier les
demandes comment on gagne l'évoquer
cette infrastructure là l'Europe n'y est
pas encore prête elle en parle tout le
monde en parle vous le retrouvez dans
les textes mais on n'y est pas en mais
est-ce que c'est parce que je sais pas
d'ailleurs si la théorie est surtout pas
il y a cette théorie de l'appel d'air
est-ce que c'est c'est pour ça que
l'Europe hésite c'est-à-dire si plus on
construit des structures d'accueil plus
il y aura de migrants candidats non mais
en fait si vous voulez quoi et la
difficulté regardez ce qui s'est
l'alternative c'est quoi l'alternative
elle existe il faut quand même le dire à
cette table c'est ce que les Grecs ont
fait le long de la rivière évrose qui
constitue la frontière entre la Grèce et
la Turquie aujourd'hui je parle de la
Grèce justement pour pas parler des pays
de vie je masse et bien vous avez un mur
de barbelés et autres dispositifs qui
l'ont cette rivière et qui fait que
désormais de moins en moins de migrants
peuvent passer bien sûr ça ne concerne
pas la partie insulaire de la Grèce qui
elle peut toujours être regagnée par
bateau donc quelle est l'alternative
soit vous construisez les murs soit vous
construisez des centres mais dans les
zones où vous pouvez accoster par bateau
et arriver par la mer de toute manière
si vous construisez pas d'infrastructure
les gens vont continuer d'arriver et le
blocus naval autre option qui avait été
proposée par Georgia Meloni elle-même
c'est infaisable l'Italie n'a pas les
moyens ni militaires ni opération de
mener ce type de blocus et je rappelle
quand même que début juillet les Grecs
l'ont fait le blocus naval parce que
quand le fameux garde grec a assaisonné
un navire de migrants avec plus de 700 à
bord 700 personnes à bord c'était une
manière de faire un blocus naval il y a
eu des centaines de morts Patrick Martin
jeudi peut-être qu'il y a un mot sur ce
blocus naval ça c'était une promesse de
campagne de Georgia Meloni c'est quoi
intenable ou intenable seul
le reproche qu'on peut faire à Madame
Meloni c'est que d'extrême droite elle a
instrumentalisé ce thème de
l'immigration et c'est un échec total la
preuve elle appelle l'Europe à la
rescousse alors qu'elle l'accusait avant
d'être laxiste il y a un effet boomerang
c'est ce que vous nous dit oui
absolument absolument et d'ailleurs la
coalition gouvernementale est un peu
déstabilisée aujourd'hui en Italie avec
Matteo Salvini le vice-président
rappelez-vous il était midi à
l'intérieur il avait lui-même fait un
blocus et donc notre interne mélodie
qu'elle a échoué ceci dit le sujet est
trop sérieux pour l'instrumentaliser ce
plan politique aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut
ce sont des moyens des moyens pour
développer ce qu'on a appelé
embarcation qui est en mer elle doit
arriver et donc il doit avoir une
exigence de rapidité par rapport à ce
qui était fait tout à l'heure je
terminerai par ça il y a une solidarité
européenne
urgente il faut que cette solution non
mais on peut le dire on peut le dire on
peut le dire mais on la voit pas
vraiment à autrement que en paroles se
mettre nous avons le risque réel que
mesure nous irions une une majorité de
droite et d'extrême droite au Parlement
européen au mois de juin 2024 si
l'Europe ne montre pas qu'elle n'est pas
capable de traiter cette situation
Matthieu ou agir moi je suis frappé par
la faiblesse de ces mesures d'urgence
annoncées par Ursula andalaïenne on nous
dit
des plus ou moins pour Frontex et pour
pour l'autre agence oui bon c'est déjà
quasiment dans les tuyaux le mécanisme
de solidarité volontaire il a quand même
été négocié en juin 2022 on m'en
souvenir sous présence française de du
Conseil de l'Union il s'est mis en place
pour un an puis avec des résultats
d'ailleurs très très mitig l'idée c'est
que des pays s'engagent sur la base du
volontariat à recueillir accueillir en
tout cas des migrants qui arrivent comme
ça étaient très bien expliqué dans dans
un pays voilà ça ça a été un peu fait
mais pas du tout les proportions qu'on
qu'on imaginait donc et puis l'aide à la
Tunisie parler à la Tunisie ça a été
fait et par George Wallonie et par ce
donc il y a rien de neuf sous le soleil
et ce qu'on nous dit que dans le pacte
migration migration il y a quoi un
mécanisme de solidarité de volontaire ah
ben encore un problème c'est que ça dure
parce qu'il y a pas au-delà de la
solidarité européenne il faudrait qu'une
position commune une unité qu'est-ce
qu'on fait face à ces vagues migratoires
qui ne sont pas circonstanciels qui ne
sont pas conjoncturelles on va arriver
dans des moments l'ONU elle a très bien
expliqué ou que ce soit à cause du
changement climatique que ce soit à
cause des conditions économiques que ce
soit à cause de circonstances
démographiques et bien il va y avoir des
mouvements de population de avec des
ordres de grandeur très très important à
l'échelle de la planète l'Europe n'est
pas la plus touchée par les flux
migratoires loin de là des réfugiés et
des demandeurs d'asile il y en a
beaucoup beaucoup plus en Asie en
Afrique les premiers les premiers pays
d'accueil des réfugiés sont souvent les
pays voisins que les gens que les gens
fuient mais il faut se poser la question
on peut hérisser tous les barbelés du
monde on peut hérisser les murs les plus
hauts possibles il y en a eu à se
tailler là je me souviens il y a 15 ans
on voyait les migrants grimper sur les
murs des des des rideaux de fer de 10
mètres de 15 m de haut il y a une
question à se poser c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on accepte ou non que les êtres
humains se déplacent sur la planète
alors je sais que quand je dis ça ça
fait vraiment
utopique ou poétique mais il y a un
moment il va falloir se poser
de 250 millions de réfugiés à l'horizon
2050 à l'échelle du globe c'est quelque
chose qui va falloir gérer autrement
qu'avec trois moyens de plus pour
Frontex et puis avec un disque de
solidarité européen votre avis là dessus
changer je sais pas le logiciel de
penser autour de ces questions
migratoires dans ce cas là il faut être
honnête et expliquer clairement que la
frontière que le principe même de
frontière n'a aucune légitimité pourquoi
pas et donc les gens pourraient s'est
passé dans le pays à l'autre sans aucune
forme de flux sans aucune forme de
contrôle et avec des situations comme on
peut le voir aujourd'hui par exemple en
France des rances où on a des migrants
qui ont été parfois déboutés qui ne sont
pas éloignés et qui sont dans des
parcours extrêmement difficiles d'un
point de vue social d'un point de vue
économique et ensuite d'un point de vue
psychique et qui ont on les voit on les
voit à Paris on les voit ailleurs en
France ensuite concernant en effet les
moyens pour les accueillir sont pas
vraiment bien mis en oeuvre non mais
ouais si je pousse la logique de de ce
que Mathieu nous disait à l'instant
est-ce que vous explique par exemple
l'Allemagne est-ce que vous expliquez
aussi la Belgique il y a quelques jours
c'est que les capacités d'accueil de ces
pays-là sont mis à rue des preuves et
qui n'ont plus les moyens de l'accueil
sur la question du logement sur la
question du logement qui est une
question qui est préoccupe énormément
les Français à juste titre et bien on a
du mal le nombre de centres
d'hébergement de cada pour les
demandeurs d'asile et ben il ne suffit
que très difficilement à suivre à suivre
la demande est-ce qu'on peut suivre sur
la question en effet sur la question de
la santé sur la question du logement sur
la question aussi économique est-ce
qu'on est en mesure de donner un emploi
leur conseille que l'immigration qu'on a
en France selon une comparaison avec les
pays d'ocde et l'une des moins
qualifiées justement de l'ensemble des
pays d'ocde c'est tout ça qu'il faut
appréhender ensuite je rejoins ce qui a
été dit il y a un besoin d'harmonisation
j'ai Macron que mais on aura l'occasion
d'y revenir que le texte justement
européen qui devra être discuté tous
dans ce sens là je dis pas juste pour
préciser il n'y a rien à faire et que
tout est facile loin de là mais je dis
juste comment être confronté à un
changement d'échelle majeur qu'il faut
anticiper et donc on peut voilà c'est
pas une histoire oui sans compter que
certains pays la solidarité européenne
ne fonctionne plus certains centres de
rétention administrative que ce soit en
Bulgarie en Roumanie ne veulent plus
garder les billes grands et les envoient
au bout de 24 heures dans d'autres pays
dont l'Allemagne et la France donc on se
renvoie la balle en quelque sorte si
vous passez l'expression ça ne marche
plus s'agissant des murs
et bien figurez-vous que la Commission
européenne a dit à un moment donné
qu'elle accepterait aussi de financer à
sa forme d'infrastructure pour mieux
protéger les frontières car c'est ça le
risque d'Europe aujourd'hui il faut
concilier l'aspect humanitaire avec cet
aspect sécurité aujourd'hui il y a une
exigence des peuples européens si on les
entend pas il y aura une majorité
d'extrême droite au Parlement européen
bientôt et il y a une exigence de
protection des frontières donc il faut
faire ça dans le respect du droit
humanitaire vous parliez de Frontex tout
à l'heure oui il y a un budget
pluriannuel qui dure jusqu'en 2027 il
doit renforcer les effectifs de contexte
mais manifestement ça ne suffit pas il
faut aussi lutter contre la criminalité
c'est pasteurs qui font payer
extrêmement cher au péril de la vie des
migrants
dernier informations venu d'Italie le
gouvernement italien qui a approuvé ce
lundi de nouvelles mesures pour endiguer
les arrivées de migrants créant
davantage de centre de rétention on est
au cœur de notre débat et en augmentant
la durée de rétention à ça c'est
intéressant aujourd'hui la durée de
rétention des immigrants en situation
irrégulières et les deux 135 toujours en
Italie si cette loi est votée se texte
passe ça passera à 18 mois il faut quand
même dire un mot riche à Verly de la
situation de Georgia Meloni parce qu'on
évoquait sa campagne électorale ses
promesses de blocus naval depuis qu'elle
est au manette ça relation à l'Union
européenne
a légèrement changé il y a beaucoup de
millions d'euros en jeu quoi alors il y
a beaucoup d'argent en jeu mais il y a
surtout une réalité à laquelle elle ne
peut pas faire face toute seule c'est la
réalité dont on débat en ce moment
c'est-à-dire ses arrivées de migrants et
qu'un blocus naval italien national ne
serait même pas possible donc je crois
qu'il y a un principe de réalité qui
s'est refermé en quelque sorte sur
Georgia Meloni ce qui est intéressant
quand même il y a deux choses d'abord il
faut faire très attention des politiques
dictées en la matière par les effets
d'annonce moi je pense que ce qui a été
fait avec la Tunisie a été bâclée
Georgia Meloni voulait un accord très
vite début juillet avec la Tunisie et
elle est avec un seul avant d'Orléans
allez voir le président tunisien on a
signé pour près d'un milliard et je 800
millions d'euros en réalité un fait de
dire que la Tunisie aujourd'hui le
gouvernement tunisien n'a pas les moyens
peut-être même pas l'intention de
contrôler ses côtes cet argent il a pas
encore été distribué c'est une promesse
l'idée comme je le voyais tout à l'heure
dans votre présentation que la Tunisie
serait un partenaire crédible disons le
ici on peut reprocher beaucoup de choses
à Monsieur Erdogan qui n'a jamais hésité
à faire du chantage aux migrants lui
aussi mais il a plutôt contrôlé la
situation des migrants dans son pays
depuis que l'accord en 2016 a été passé
entre l'Union européenne et la Turquie
c'est pas du tout le cas de la Tunisie
donc là on a un problème c'est qu'on a
un pays sur lequel malheureusement on ne
peut pas s'appuyer et je ferai une
petite un petit détour d'actualité
regardez ce qui se passe en ce moment
Libye avec cette terrible c'est terrible
inondations à Bernard même si Bernard
c'est loin de Lampedusa vous pouvez être
sûr que avec des catastrophes de ce type
l'état dans lequel est la Libye avec en
plus le flot d'armes qui circule en
Libye la Tunisie n'aura pas les moyens
ni demain ni après demain de contrôler
ses côtes et on revient à la
démonstration tout à l'heure sur les les
migrants on va dire climatiques parce
que on est dans ce cas de figure pas
c'est simplement pour ajouter par
rapport à ce que vous dites cet accord
avec la Tunisie oui a été critiqué mais
Ursula femme d'hallenge a été critiqué
par le Conseil européen le responsable
de la politique extérieure Joseph
Fontanès qui a estimé qu'elle n'avait
pas consulté des États membres donc il y
a en plus de cette crise migratoire une
crise institutionnelle en Europe parce
qu'on l'a accusé d'avoir été trop vite
de ne pas avoir été suffisamment préparé
cet accord avec la Tunisie alors il y a
les questions évidemment on a évoqué
vous les avez vécu évoqué les uns les
autres de cette perspective des
élections européennes au mois de juin
beaucoup de personnalités politiques qui
ont débarqué à Lampedusa depuis une
semaine par exemple on a appris un
exemple la tête de liste du parti
reconquête ici en français Marion
maréchalant l'écoute
une grande partie des gens que nous
voyons aujourd'hui seront probablement
dans une semaine et dans un mois en
France et donc je souhaiterais ici pour
appeler un changement de politique au
niveau européen et aussi à une
responsabilité des gouvernements membres
de l'espace Schengen afin qu'ils
arrêtent d'envoyer des signaux
d'ouverture qui contribuent aujourd'hui
à la situation humanitaire que nous
voyons aujourd'hui à l'anglais 12 ans
Matthieu lampée 12a pour pour l'extrême
droite pour la droite radicale c'est
vraiment l'occasion rêvé pour lancer la
campagne des européennes ah bah oui et
puis depuis quelques jours on a assisté
à un festival d'instrumentalisation
politique de ce drame sans vergogue mais
bon l'occasion était trop belle pour
l'extrême droite française tant le drame
de Lampedusa leur offre un terrain de
jeu si je peux me permettre cette
expression
idéale d'abord parce que ça permet de
surfer sur l'espèce de réflexe
identitaire on le sait qui qui constitue
leur matrice ensuite parce que ça permet
de dénoncer l'Europe passoire l'Union
européenne maire de tous les mots en la
matière et puis parce que ça permet
aussi de cibler Emmanuel Macron sur la
question de la possible répartition des
réfugiés entre entre les États membres
donc coup sur coup on a vu Marion
maréchal on vient d'avoir pour le parti
reconquête Marine Le Pen pour le
rassemblement national faire le
déplacement en Italie alors la première
à lampe p12a dans les pas de Satan parce
que Marine Le Pen a fait exactement le
même coup en 2011 voilà juste après ce
récession à la tête du Front national à
l'époque elle a son premier déplacement
à l'étranger était allé pedoza et Marine
Le Pen elle était prête Bergame c'est un
une visite qui était prévu pour rendre
rendre visite à son ami Mateo Salvini
donc qui tenait la fête annuelle de la
Ligue là-bas en Italie que propose-t-il
si on rentre dans le détail sans
surprise le rassemblement national
propose de ne pas accepter un seul
migrant sur le territoire ce qui
sous-entend de mettre fin mettre un
terme en tout cas au mécanisme de
solidarité en vigueur qu'on a vu qui
déjà fonctionne déjà pas très bien et
puis en équipe mettre fin aussi au pacte
au paquet européen là pour les
migrations
pour Jord regarder là le président du
Rassemblement national les élections
européennes doivent être selon lui
l'occasion de dire no way il a dit un
tweet donc une rageur de référendum
contre l'Union européenne coupable selon
lui avec son agence Frontex était devenu
je cite des hôtesses d'accueil pour
migrants donc ça c'est pour le
rassemblement national qui développe par
ailleurs son référendum sur
l'immigration en France la priorité
nationale bref toutes les mesures qu'on
sait déjà du côté de reconcrète pas un
seul migrant sur le sol français non
plus donc copier-coller mais avec un pas
supplémentaire franchit un terme de
vocabulaire en tout cas pour Éric
Zemmour il faut d'ailleurs plus parler
de réfugiés ni même de migrants mais
d'envahisseurs c'est un mot qui la
prononcé ce week-end sur BFM TV ces gens
là ne sont pas des victimes et Dirick
Zemmour ce sont des entrepreneurs en
exil capables de payer de 5 à 10.000
euros le passage j'ajoute que Eric
Ciotti aujourd'hui pour les LR a dit pas
un seul migrant sur le territoire
français non plus donc on le voit bien
on a entendu
immersion invasion et je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure en ouverture de cette émission
je rappelle juste que le total des
arrivées en Italie cette année même s'il
est élevé et plus élevé que les années
passées représente 0,03 pour cent de la
population européenne on est assez loin
de la submersion mais la pression sur
l'exécutif fait son effet oui parce que
prix Emmanuel Macron il est pris en étau
dans son et en même temps on l'a entendu
c'est devoir de solidarité avec les
États membres approche humanitaire mais
en même temps fermeté aux frontières
c'est sûr que c'est une passion qui
n'est pas facile à tenir et qui en tout
cas manque de lisibilité pour une partie
des Français c'est sans doute pas un
hasard si Gérald Darmanin qui prépare
son projet de loi immigration a trop
peur de passer pour un laxiste l'extrême
droite en fait n'a pas remporté une
élection nationale en France mais sur la
question de l'immigration elle a
définitivement j'espère pas remporter la
bataille culturelle Rachel Minas où sont
les voies de gauche sur ces questions
d'immigration et est-ce que ça veut
encore dire quelque chose pour vous on
les a un petit peu entendu autour de
l'immigration de travail
on a vu en effet une partie de la gauche
expliquée appelée de ses vœux justement
la régularisation
des personnes des migrants qui qui
travaillent alors il y a une pour les
métiers en tension exactement en tout
cas c'était on va dire le pied la jambe
gauche du projet immigration du
gouvernement incarné par Olivier du
socle avec la jambe droite incarné par
Gérald Darmanin et qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité
en ces termes à l'Assemblée et au Sénat
ensuite oui il y a une gêne de toute une
partie de la gauche sur ces questions là
alors même que la charge de l'accueil à
certains égards repose davantage sur les
classes populaires les gens qui sont un
petit peu moins privilégiés et bien on
observe une partie de la gauche qui a du
mal qui a du mal avec ce sujet c'est une
espèce de tabou alors on a en effet d'un
côté une gauche qui est plutôt
silencieuse ou du moins assez discrète
sur ces questions là et puis comme ça a
été souligné une extrême droite qui a
opté pour le Yaka faucon comme si cette
équation pouvait se résoudre de manière
extrêmement facile
et sans aucun état d'âme on voit en tout
cas que en France
les parties politiques et les politiques
de manière générale ont du mal à dégager
une ligne contrairement à d'autres pays
on pourrait penser à par exemple la
gauche la gauche danoise qui elle a un
discours beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
affirmé sur ces questions là Patrick
Martin Genier sur Mathieu disait
bataille culturelle sur l'immigration
gagné par par l'extrême droite ou la
droite radicale est-ce que c'est vrai au
niveau européen écoutez ce que vous
dites attention attention si on ne fait
rien vous espérez que ces élections sont
remportées par par les non parce que il
y a encore beaucoup de force sociale
démocrates de gauche quand un discours
quand même rationnel regardez l'extrême
droite en Espagne c'était fondé
récemment donc ça ne veut pas dire il y
a un risque mais je ne pense pas que
voilà ce serait ce soit le cas donc au
Parlement européen au mois de juin 2024
mais il faut se méfier en effet mais
reprend par nos interrompre les termes
de bataille culturel est-ce que
finalement pour remporter ces élections
ou ne pas les perdre il faut à la voir
intégré le durcissement à la à la Front
national ou à la rassemblement national
face aux questions je veux dire il faut
avoir un discours responsable vous savez
moi je me rappelle Manuel Valls à
l'intérieur a été beaucoup critiqué mais
il avait fait une circulaire qui était
très pertinente qui consistait à dire
nous manquons de main d'oeuvre dans un
certain nombre de secteurs qui dans les
restaurants et qui est toujours en
vigueur et qui est très bien fait parce
que on voit bien que dans certains
secteurs et bien il n'y a plus de de
main d'oeuvre française ce sont c'est
une main d'oeuvre étrangère ce sont des
gens qui cotisent ce sont des gens qui
payent des retraites et donc à partir
d'un certain moment il faut avoir un
discours rationnel je crois que en ce
qui nous concerne les Françaises les
Français sont capables d'écouter ce
genre de discours de ne pas céder à
l'instrumentalisation d'extrême droite
lorsque la effectivement l'immigration
est utile et en Allemagne on va avoir
besoin de cette main d'oeuvre immigrée
et bien il faut réfléchir vous citer la
gauche néerlandaise ou danoise qui a mis
en place un système de points également
comment en Australie et savoir on a
besoin d'une main d'oeuvre économique on
doit pouvoir la choisir ce qui est tout
à fait légitime donc c'est ça sur quoi
il faut insister et bien se dire nous
sommes d'accord pour contrôler les
frontières tout en ayant un discours
raisonnable je suis pas certain si vous
voulez que ce soit parfaitement
rationnel entendable lorsque il y a une
instrumentalisation notamment lorsqu'on
voit monsieur Orban en Hongrie qui est
très clairement est en train de nous
dire nous ne nous voulons plus de
musulmans chez nous car nous sommes un
peuple et chrétiens et c'est là où il y
a un vrai discours un vrai risque c'est
ce discours tout à fait culturel et
ethnique Richard Verly vous voyez
vraiment avoir envie de réagir peut-être
plusieurs nuances d'abord le
gouvernement vous parliez des Pays-Bas
le gouvernement néerlandais De Marco est
tombé sur l'immigration c'est à dire que
même dans les mêmes au Pays-Bas pays
réputés pragmatique et raisonnable il
n'y a plus aujourd'hui de consensus
raisonnable sur l'immigration c'est
deuxième chose vogue en Espagne ne s'est
pas effondré ils ont eu moins nettement
moins de siège qui ne l'espérait mais
comme la droite espagnole s'est
rapprochée de l'extrême droite au fond
la thématique antimigration de Vox à
emporter une nuance il y a un mot qu'on
n'a pas prononcé ici c'est l'Ukraine
n'oublions quand même pas qui est arrivé
depuis 2 ans une vague très importante
du crédit qui fait que des pays comme la
Pologne et la Hongrie qu'on stigmatisé
pour le refus d'accueillir aujourd'hui
sont parmi ceux qui quantitativement
accueille le plus de réfugiés
qui enfin voilà on a bien compris
pourquoi ils étaient prêts les
accueillir complètement la posture et la
même chose quand même à propos des
métiers en tension certes mais il y a
aujourd'hui et ça vient d'être dit on ne
peut pas simplement dire il y a des
métiers qui ont besoin de main d'oeuvre
et il y a la une main d'oeuvre
disponible parce que derrière se pose la
question du logement de l'accueil un
certain nombre de choses auxquelles on
ne sait pas trouver réponse moi ce qui
m'afflige du côté de l'Union européenne
et notamment du côté de la Commission
européenne il y a des pans entiers de
compétences de distribution européenne
qui pourrait être mis en parenthèse
entre parenthèses la Commission
européenne déploie énormément d'argent
énormément d'effectifs un certain nombre
de domaines on pourrait dire aujourd'hui
on arrête de travailler sur des domaines
périphériques qui touchent à par exemple
je lance ça en l'air à l'éducation ou à
d'autres choses et la Commission
européenne pourrait décréter un
branle-bas de combat de combat en disant
nous avons 30 000 fonctionnaires sur ces
30000 fonctionnaires on en met 5000 sur
le sujet migration parce que c'est
l'urgence pourquoi la Commission
européenne ne le fait pas
la commission excusez-moi elle est pas
seule on parlait des lenteurs du
processus il y a la commission il y a le
Conseil des ministres qui a présenté
à la question initiale de l'impuissance
de l'Europe à 27 avec ces structures
sont administration c'est l'odeur il y a
maintenant commissaire et il n'y a même
pas une tasse force d'urgence à la
Commission européenne sur les questions
migratoires il y a un commissaire qui a
la charge de dossier mais il n'y a
toujours pas de tasforce d'urgence sur
les questions migratoires
ce qui vient d'être dit sur le sur
l'Ukraine et très juste on remarquera
jusqu'au on en parle pas de la même
façon mais non jusque dans le
vocabulaire c'est très bien pour les
Ukrainiens on parlait de réfugiés de
gens qui fuyaient leur pays le cas aussi
de pour ceux qui traversent la
Méditerranée une partie d'entre eux pour
une partie d'entre eux je dis pas tous
mais pour une partie d'entre eux il y a
aussi cette notion de réfugiés il fut la
misère même si même s'il fuit pas un
régime autocratique ou des persécutions
les termes que disait Patrick Martin
Genier sur la le genre la sexualité etc
il fut la misère certes mais c'est un
sujet suffisamment sensible et pour sur
lequel il faut pas travestir les mots si
vous voulez quand l'OFPRA ou la CNDA
accorde une protection il faut remplir
certains certains
d'entrepreneurs franchement bien entendu
non mais on va pas commencer à faire
économique donc finalement c'est du
business quoi non c'est pas ils viennent
juste gagner de l'argent sans considère
que l'offrey et la CNDA font leur
travail parce qu'ils ont ils ont
identifié justement des critères
particuliers qui permettent de
bénéficier soit d'une protection
subilière soit soit de voilà de l'Asie
et c'est une chose soit en effet ce sont
des gens qui relèvent on appelle ça
d'une immigration plus économique ça ne
veut pas dire que la situation n'est pas
terrible dans leur pays et qu'on ferait
pas la même chose à leur place mais tout
ne peut pas être mis tout ne peut pas
être lissé de cette manière parce que
sinon c'est notre c'est notre système
entier qui qui s'écroulait les mots
n'ont plus aucun sens et on voit bien
qu'il est dans la société
temporaire pour les Ukrainiens via des
prolongés d'un an récemment donc
effectivement ce que dit Mathieu est
très il y a effectivement de poids et de
mesure il faut le reconnaître n'oublions
pas que la Pologne a pratiqué ce qu'on
appelle le pushback c'est-à-dire qu'ils
ont envoyé des personnes qui étaient
réfugiées rappelez-vous lors de la crise
migratoire en Biélorussie et bien ils
n'ont eux-mêmes pas respecté La
convention de jeunesse chez les rêves
merci beaucoup merci à tous c'était
passionnant je rappelle le titre de
votre livre Patrick Martin Geny l'Europe
Athéna navire aux éditions Studyrama et
évidemment rachelinas pour Marianne
Richard Verly pour lui qu'on suit vos
articles dans les magazines et sur les
sites de vos médias respectifs à très
bientôt sur public